é um emaranhado é uma confusão é um
iluminado decoração um é gente do lado
sem uma ligação é um concentrado de
ilusão não se resolve o longe
centeno perto a solução e não cabe numa
caixa o que é pra ser e mercy dão
imensidão imensidão a 1
a vida é expressão o fluxo da vida
depende do quanto nos expressarmos uma
expressão do amor no eu me expresso
diretamente pelo corpo porque escolhi
como profissão a dança a música e o
teatro num mas foi buscando maneiras de
me conhecer e de resolver minhas
questões que eu descobri a constelação
sistêmica ou constelação familiar como é
conhecida é uma dinâmica terapêutico que
foi desenvolvida pelo alemão bert heaven
nessa dinâmica
o objetivo principal é a gente descobrir
e revelar as nossas atitudes que estão
atrelados aos nossos sistemas familiares
sociais e profissionais ou religiosos
atitudes que muitas vezes impedem o
nosso fluxo a nossa expressão um atitude
que a gente erra e abraça dos nossos
sistemas principalmente os familiares e
na maioria das vezes são a atitude que a
gente nem se dar conta
então nessa dinâmica as atitudes
aparecem através do que chamamos de
campo tem a intenção do congelador
a autorização ea o desejo de quem vai
ser consolado e o campo se manifesta
através de representantes que podem ser
pessoas podem ser objetos ou até mesmo
animais e o conservador ele percebe o
que está bloqueando o fluxo daquela
pessoa e também percebe aquilo que pode
fazer voltar fluir o fluxo da pessoa
isso tudo através do campo e o que eu
chamava de acontecimento nas artes
eu percebi que é a mesma coisa é o campo
nas constelações e se esse acontecimento
sempre foi tudo o que eu mais gostei no
meu fazer artístico
vejam só toda expressão ela passa pelo
corpo certo mas na constelação das
constelações mais tradicionais
os procedimentos são basicamente o
seguinte você é o consolador a pessoa
que vai ser congelada chega com a
questão
o constelador decide o que ou quem vai
representar os seus representantes são
escolhidos e dispostos na sala utah e
lembro a primeira vez que eu fui não
aquece uma constelação
eu já fui convidado para representar o
pai de um adolescente
eu lembro que no meio da dinâmica eu
estava completamente tomado por uma
emoção muito forte e eu eu chorava
compulsivamente
mas ao mesmo tempo eu olhava aquilo tudo
que estava acontecendo era como se eu ea
pessoa que eu estava representando
estivesse ali
e ao mesmo tempo aí quando acabou a
dinâmica valeu o é e sete atr que sempre
que busquem no teatro exatamente isso
esse acontecimento aquilo que eu vi
acontecer na na dinâmica é algo é um
acontecimento que traz uma nova
percepção dos fatos e da vida de um modo
geral né então eu comecei a fazer
participar de grupos é eu me considerei
várias vezes e 15 anos depois dessa
primeira vez eu me informava constelador
com ana da fonte do instituto
constelação aí ainda no início do curso
eu fui dar uma oficina na cidade de
russas interior do ceará para atores e
dançarinos
na primeira noite depois do primeiro dia
de oficina eu fui tomado por uma emoção
muito forte também só que dessa vez
muito conflituoso porque era um chamado
para eu abrir as constelações e foi
muito conflituoso porque eu estava bem
no início do curso né
essa noite eu não dormi mas eu decidi ok
amanhã eu abro constelações eu trabalhei
exatamente com pessoas que estavam com
dificuldades expressa para cada pessoa
eu convidei outras duas uma para
representar aquilo que bloqueava a
expressão da pessoa e outra para
representar o que iria fazer fluir
só que eu pedi para as pessoas
expressarem aquilo através de dança
e o resultado foi muito bonito foi muito
forte e também muito eficaz quando eu
encontrei ana novamente
eu falei dessa experiência para um
pouquinho assim e batizo aquela forma
que eu tinha descoberto em fazer
constelação de constelação dançante
o procedimento é o mesmo está e os
objetivos também que é
e aquilo que impede o nosso fluxo nossa
expressão
só que a diferença é que o campo se
manifesta em forma de dança
aí eu percebi por porque eu percebi isso
porque o que impede a gente disse
expressar em forma de dança é a mesma
coisa que impede a gente de viver melhor
então a partir daí eu eu entendi que o
meu olhar apurado para a dança poderia
servir plenamente ao meu papel como
terapeuta nas constelações e uma
percepção importante também o seguinte
se a gente trabalha para resolver nossas
questões vai se expressar melhor
da mesma forma se a gente trabalhar para
se expressar melhor a gente também
resolvem nossas questões
e como tudo passa pelo corpo claro que
são infinitas as possibilidades de se
expressar mas não tem como você ausentar
o seu corpo tudo vai passar pelo corpo
por isso a gente trabalhar aquela
expressão que passa diretamente pelo
corpo tem uma potência muito grande ea
dança é uma dessas possibilidades e eu
também acho sim que dança todo e
qualquer ser humano é capaz de dançar
porque a dança é um ditado em um estado
que todo e qualquer ser humano pode
acessar
aí eu fico investigando certo porque
tudo na vida precisa de treino
eu fico pensando justamente como é que a
gente pode treinar essa expressão por
onde é que a expressão acontece
diretamente pelo corpo
eu vou mostrar uma dessas investigações
para que vocês levem para casa e
pratiquem lá tá certo é dedos dos pés
aqui no sapato mas um dedos dos pés
pés pernas e quadril coluna ombro braço
mãos dedos das mãos e pescoço olhos boca
e língua o que é que isso tem de comum
são articulações são nas articulações
o o veículo por onde a expressão
acontece por isso que só a gente
movimentar as articulações
a gente já se expressa eu vou fazer isso
percebam claro que precisa praticar mais
percebo como é expressivo simplesmente
movimentar as articulações percebam
também com mais simples
[Música]
hum
é simples mas não é fácil porque são nas
articulações
onde a gente deposita as nossas questões
por isso que só é movimentar as
articulações
a gente já messi já mexe com as questões
mas a gente quer ir mais longe
a gente precisa a gente pode ir mais
longe se a gente se permite z esse
veículo do estado da dança
eu vou me expressar agora através da
dança e da música com a música que está
no meu cd 'samba do assim como o poema
que abriu essa palestra é e também com a
conquest a música essa dança também
expõe o mais diretamente o meu olhar
sobre o tema desse tag que é
transmontana são
[Música]
a tok se paz presente é quando a gente
ainda aceita o que encheu no passado
[Música]
ou pode ser um presente porque quando a
gente mente pé ceb o fio pra ser cortado
[Música]
por que arranca pedaço é quanto a gente
se perde no espaço e não sei o que faz
perder o chão
[Música]
dom do caminho é um pedaço e que só que
a gente no espaço e no tempo que traz
conectam
[Música]
aproveitar
a própria dor e inventar uma nova corro
[Música]
para o que ser para o que for na própria
é uma nova turma
[Música]
o
o v
[Música]
eu to
uma nova
o que quiser
para o que ficou
ae
o amor é o tchan para encerrar eu quero
dividir mais alguns aprendizados e as
constelações entrou servo e que são bem
importantes a fazer fluir a nossa
expressão é o primeiro é alto
responsabilidade a gente entender que
tudo o que acontece na nossa vida é
responsabilidade nossa
isso é muito libertador porque as
soluções estão com a gente e também a
gente não precisa assumir
responsabilidade por ninguém
outro aprendizado é aceitação dos nossos
pais como que a gente pode se expressar
plenamente sem aceitar plenamente quem
nos deu a vida é entender também que
todas as experiências que acontece
conosco
são 1 para o nosso desenvolvimento e por
fim é que essas convenções só são
possíveis se a gente olhar para a vida
sem julgamento o julgamento incluindo o
alto julgamento talvez seja aquilo que
mais bloqueia a gente disse expressar
então essa compreensão
[Música]
ela retorna a gente mais expressivo se a
gente se expressa mais a nossa vida é
mais fluida a vida sendo fluida nossa
vida também se torna uma expressão do
amor no obrigado
[Aplausos]
o